there's nowhere worse than device the
only city in the world where the women
are far more promiscuous than the men
because what's happened to the women
that come to rich cities is they come
emotionally detached they come with the
idea that I want to meet a rich man now
that woman is completely different to
the woman that comes to a city and says
I want to fall in love and have kids now
that emotionally detached woman who
comes I want a good life is never
emotionally invested and here's the
mistake a lot of rich men make they seem
to think that if they can support a girl
and give her a good life loyalty is a
given but what they're forgetting is a
woman that craves a good life doesn't
seek emotional intimacy she seeks
financial intimacy any woman who doesn't
seek emotional intimacy is far more
likely to stray the most likely to be
cheated on is these men that spoil their
women because loyal women want to be
spoiled by time they don't want to be
spoiled by possessions